uh Lebron you guys were outrebounded
most of the game what changed for you
guys in that fourth quarter
uh I don't know I think we just finally
got sick of being outrebounded we kept
bodies in front of bodies I think uh SE
wood did a great job of cleaning glass
start that fourth and we was able to hit
so we finally started hitting our
three-pointers down and that that
definitely helped us get back into the
game the Stars definitely came out
tonight on both sides but how were you
guys able to keep Kevin Durant from
beating you down the uh
I mean can you really stop him from
beting you I mean you just I saw you
guys had him trapped over here yeah yeah
you got to you have to you got to put
two or three four bodies on him at times
cuz he's that he's that good he's really
that good I mean he's great I'm sorry
don't let me disrespect Kevin Durant but
um we did a good job of just trying to
make it tough U throughout the game but
he's he's excellent player cam reddish
got the start tonight what did he show
you uh nothing I've already known this
in Cam and uh to all the uh naysayers
and basketball Savant that don't know
nothing about basketball and telling me
I should have shot that shot in Miami
instead of passing to cam reddish well I
did the same thing tonight because I
trust my teammates and I make the right
play every single time and uh game ball
go to cam reddish for sure and likewise
the impact that Austin Rees had the
adjustment that he made as well coming
off the bench he's just a big time
player he can fit in any role uh when
you have a guy that can fit in any rooll
starter come off the bench play on the
ball play off the ball it makes it a lot
easier on the team and AR can do that so
easy transition for him lastly first
road win how good does it feel to
finally get that over with it feels
great because it's the End season
tournament win and we'll take that we'll
take that for sure I heard it's 500,000
on the line so we going for we're going
for that we're going for that you want
to
share maybe we'll see we see
congrats